you might have learned the formula for  the sum of numbers from 1 to n in school  but why is it true  here is a wonderful visualization  imagine you are summing the numbers from  1 to n shown here for n equals five  the sum is exactly the total number of  circles in the Triangular grid  now let's count this in another way  add the next row which has n plus one  circles and create a triangular mesh  for every pair of circles in the bottom  row their lines intersect at exactly one  Circle in the top grid therefore the  total number of circles in the top grid  is exactly equal to n plus 1 choose 2.  by equivalence of two counting methods  we have shown the sum of numbers from 1  to n is equal to n plus one choose two  this simplifies to be n multiplied by n  plus 1 over 2. q e d